[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy hablaremos del memorable
discurso de martin luther king
su figura activista y su movimiento
social detrás de la lucha de los
derechos civiles afroamericanos
[Aplausos]
cuando tengo un sueño que un día el
estado de alabama donde los labios de su
gobernador están goteando actualmente
con palabras de interposición y
anulación se transformará en un
escenario en el que los niños y las
niñas negras podrán unir sus manos con
los niños blancos y las niñas blancas y
caminar juntos como hermanas y hermanos
hoy tengo un sueño
[Música]
la historia de martin luther king cobra
gran significado en estos tiempos
turbulentos donde la violencia policial
ha silenciado la vida de personas por la
discriminación y por su color de piel
ser negro en eeuu carga una impronta
histórica de resentimiento desde que los
estados del sur perdieron la guerra de
secesión contra los estados del norte a
finales del siglo 19
eeuu quedó profundamente dividido
quedaba abolida la esclavitud de los
afroamericanos pero explosionaba el
rencor de los supremacistas blancos los
negros ya no estarían esclavizados pero
si segregados y por ley con barrios por
aparte hospitales por aparte escuelas
por aparte y siempre cediendo el puesto
ante un blanco de manera que martin
luther king dotado de una capacidad
oratoria magistral encontró un nicho de
protestas en la ciudad de montgomery
cuando la afroamericana rosa parks fue
arrestada en 1955 por subvertir el orden
de alabama al sentarse en una silla de
autobús destinada para los blancos el
doctor king leader
una serie de manifestaciones para
boicotear el sistema de autobuses el eco
de los primeros discursos del doctor kim
que resonó fuerte los ciudadanos negros
dejaron de tomar autobuses y se
movilizaron por sus propios medios
fueran a donde fueran es decir
impactaron la economía pero el boicot
que duró más de un año no caló bien
entre los blancos no solo apresaron al
doctor king sino que le lanzaron bombas
incendiarias a su casa pero la lucha
marcó un hito la corte suprema de los
estados unidos proclamó como ilegal en
1956 la segregación racial en autobuses
restaurantes y escuelas este triunfo
marcó el norte de martin luther king lo
suyo sería apelar por la igualdad en el
100% de los derechos civiles de los
afroamericanos emulando la desobediencia
civil no violenta de mahatma gandhi sin
embargo el movimiento de quin fue
acusado de ser comunista en plena guerra
fría tuvo un atentado de muerte en 1958
y luego pasó a estar en la mira del fbi
en 1961
por varias ocasiones fue arrestado y su
proyecto de derechos civiles parecía
esfumarse tanto por la violencia de los
afros que no entendían las protestas
pacíficas como por la discriminación de
las autoridades segregacionistas entre
los derechos que exigía el doctor kings
estaban elevar el nivel de participación
del voto afro que por entonces era de
apenas un 10% también equiparar el
disparejo salario entre negros y blancos
pero ni el apoyo que tuvo del presidente
john fitzgerald kennedy transformó la
forma de pensar de los policías como un
reflejo de lo que pasa en la actualidad
en varias protestas pacíficas que kim
logró organizar en birmingham la ciudad
más grande del estado de alabama la
policía hizo uso de la violencia era tan
evidente la violencia racial que en
lugar de decirle birmingham y acuña bam
bam bingham de bomba y la comparaban con
el aparte de áfrica al no encontrar una
tangente para la espiral de
discriminación racial varias
organizaciones que luchaban por los
derechos civiles afroamericanos
organizaron una histórica marcha en
washington
asistieron 250.000 personas que pudieron
escuchar el famoso discurso de martin
luther king' de aquel sueño de niños
negros y blancos que pudieran jugar
juntos como hermanos el impacto
mediático y político de su discurso más
el creciente movimiento por los derechos
civiles afroamericanos logró su cometido
en 1964 tras el asesinato de john
fitzgerald kennedy el presidente lyndon
johnson paradójicamente un blanco
proveniente de un estado sureño presentó
la ley más avanzada de derechos civiles
ante el congreso que luego fue aprobada
en síntesis la segregación sería hallada
inconstitucional y dejaría de ser puesta
en práctica por todos los estados pero
una cosa es la ley en el papel y otra en
la práctica la violencia policial y la
de los segregacionistas en contra de los
negros nunca se detuvo sólo basta
recordar el simbólico episodio de la
piscina del hotel monzón un policía
blanco se lanzó al agua para arrestar a
varios activistas negros que allí se
bañaban y ante la negativa el propio
dueño del hotel
vertió ácido clorhídrico en la piscina
la lucha de martin luther king' continuó
por cuatro años más su activismo integró
las causas de abolir la pobreza y
renunciar a la participación
estadounidense en la guerra de vietnam
su determinación pacífica en aras de su
movimiento social le valió el premio
nobel de la paz en 1964 pero en 1968 en
memphis tennessee para apoyar las
huelgas de los negros recolectores de
basuras fue asesinado
actualmente más de 50 años después su
lucha sigue inconclusa y su sueño no
parece despertar pero su causa se
mantiene en pie que lo diga a su hijo
the nation es nave la nación nunca ha
visto un movimiento tan poderoso una
encarnación moderna de lo que mi padre
llamó la coalición de conciencia y si
avanzamos con propósito y pasión
completaremos el trabajo que comenzamos
con tanta valentía en los años 1960
hasta aquí llegamos soy andrés suárez
jaramillo gracias por compartir estas
historias que las encuentran en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]